сама проковтнута днр я картовий буду і
ніг який думаєте на місце в їхніх тузах то
чистках вона одному єдиному джо кору в
роту його ви зміг ну ти і вся конструкція
розвалиться так і на хитрі олафом області
візуальних образ виводок донецької
художник серед захарів хтось просто листи
хтось буваєте вдома я родом із донецька я
народився в донецьку і я не народився в
донецькому і я жива донецьку я за кермом
нажити а дизайну меблів в інтер'єрі
як художник я проти в краще для
свого завдання
олег вул і твоє місце пачино і притворі
ось і синці місіс змітить нік яму врахуйте
шакли ви it in для частини ми каємось краю
хотілося приклад із вами про цінову
стріт-арту зробив це я закон
стріт-артом sleep не пср поні 2014 на
полатях донецька була а персонажів
захарова і ти виступав під псевдонімом
мурзилка сову зайві до кульки у
булгакова жолобків ти знову не x a
protest motorola
з молодою та дружиною насправді ті
люди які нас правді їжте людовіку
вчора сиділа на лаві з фляжку та пиво ти
лузер її кибли алкоголіками та
наркоманами геть і вийшла на вулицю вона в
руках у них уже було зброя
вони вийшли на вулицю і в руках у не ж
була зброя такі ж не ту ж річ я
велю daze зброю прийшли на території
донецька вам центру ізоляція до мрії
зайву фабрику фарсі чув і все про знак
із жахливої ​​майстерності території
ізоляції пара творив і вже точно читав
визнати і знайдену у донецьку
по суті у підвалі закопані з
протесту ми будемо збу вікон і вся сама
художник захару
витрати ж не протестні радіальність та
донецький бенкси розпад і вся частина матері
і знімуть артур то побої
крутіше його виводили на розстріл 3 вирішити
раз поvestea профспілковим трапилося нові
коміксі
перший день першого дня був великий досвід
у мене був ісламу не ребра і забув
опаришів із сіна Ваня розстрілу потім
буду інфікування розстрілу табель
жіночі тур тури
сьогодні серед живих укрили
робот виставка прибрали не довіряти що
коли так і поверніть урини місцем хай і
нашвидкуруч